you know what this outdated music means
it's ps+ time once again this is the
last PS Plus in its current form ps3 and
Vita won't be supported as of March 2019
so let's see what we get this one final
time as always these games will be
available from the first Tuesday of the
month which is February the fifth first
let's check out the ps4 offering some
bloody hell they're impressive first up
is the game which pits samurai against
Vikings against knights of the round
table this is for honor first released
two years ago for honor got off to a
slow start but like so many Ubisoft
titles it has built into an impressive
game we fight against other players or
AI to secure points of interest on the
battlefield but the only way to win this
war is by slicing your opposition in two
with deadly decapitations each character
has a different way of playing with
their own skills weapons and fighting
styles to master them all is quiet tasks
original reviews were all over the place
with Destructoid giving it a low 5 point
5 out of 10 and GameSpot and IGN
awarding it 8 out of 10 I played last
month and can vouch for the improvements
for honor has started to implement live
events in game last month we could link
to the world of Assassin's Creed so
expect other crossovers in the months
and years to come the only thing to do
now is settle the argument who would win
in a fight a Viking a knight a samurai
or my dad I'm serious the polls on the
screen right now next up is my game of
the year for 2016 hitman and not only
that it's the complete first season
which includes the patient zero DLC and
some limited edition costumes like a
clown because who doesn't want to go on
a murder spree dressed as a middle-aged
clown
if you don't know hitman let me break it
down we play as agent 47 and go
globe-trotting to eliminate targets it's
possible to run and gun your way to the
objective but the real skill is getting
in unnoticed and leaving the same way
once the job is done of course in that
respect hitman demands concentration and
a complete understanding of the mission
map and the routines of many NPCs and
not only that each mission has multiple
ways to get the job done so be a
professional I'll go on the warpath the
choice is yours
the missions came out episodically in
2016 so it's hard to get
an overall review score so averaging
everything together we get the
Metacritic score of 80 out of 100 pretty
damn impressive do me a favor please
download this game you'll be surprised
how great it is over on the ps3 for what
could be the very last time and what a
game to end on Metal Gear Solid 4 guns
of the Patriots
without a doubt one of the greatest
games to grace the ps3 we play a
prematurely aged Solid Snake known as
Old Snake and barking on his last
mission we stealth our way into enemy
locations and unravel the plot which
started for many of us back in 1998 mgs
far received many perfect scores so if
you haven't played it now is the perfect
chance a truly great way to say goodbye
to PS + on ps3 another great title on
the ps3 but at the completely other end
of the scale is divekick a 2d fighting
game in the most basic of ways the game
is completely based around diving and
kicking and is so ridiculous you won't
realize you've wasted six hours doing
the same thing repeatedly divekick is
also available on your Vita and
functioned surprisingly well there it
won't stay on your system for very long
but it is extremely fun to play
especially with friends over on the Vita
and two more games which are
downloadable on your ps4 first up is gun
house released last year and is
essentially a tower defense game
protecting orphans whilst defeating
ridiculous bosses like many games that
do what this one does what you see is
what you get if this floats your boat
then rack up the death count and finally
the last PS Vita game which as a
reminder is available on your ps4 to his
rogue aces it's an arcade shooter and
it's a damn good one travel around the
war zone destroying planes buildings and
there's even Zeppelin's here too it's
fun for funs sake there's no real story
just loads of pixelated to display genes
what do you think downloading it so
there we have it six games to get our
teeth into this month what you're
grabbing I already have the ps4 titles
but I am looking forward to cutting your
head off in for honor and I can't resist
that arcade shooter rogue aces what
about you watching grabbing I am Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure as always I'll see you next
time
how did you vote in the poll you voted
for my dad didn't you yeah cause she did